all right welcome to class everybody so
today is really exciting because we're
going to start talking about partial
differential equations which is probably
the most useful topic that you're gonna
learn in 564 565 so partial differential
equations are really the backbone of how
we describe most physical systems of
interest okay and so we're gonna learn a
few important things over the next maybe
four to five weeks so we're going to
learn how to take a physical system that
we're interested in and write down a
model in terms of a partial differential
equation so we're gonna learn to build
PDE s to describe systems that we're
interested in we're going to learn
techniques to find solutions to those
PDE s so solutions to our system in
space and time and we're also going to
learn how to interpret those solutions
okay so really important stuff and I
thought I would just give a couple of
motivating YouTube examples because this
is one of the things I like about
partial differential equations is that
one of the things I like about partial
differential equations is that you can
get really really cool movies out of
them and great visualizations because
the entire idea is that your partial
differential equation is describing how
some quantity of interest like
temperature or fluid velocity or
position evolves both in space and in
time
okay and so that spacial temporal
relationship basically means great
movies so this is a movie of flow past a
sphere this is the solution to the
navier-- stokes equations and this is
flow past a dimpled golf ball and so you
can see
the difference in the top and the bottom
does anyone know right off the top of
their head what's the main difference in
the top and the bottom smooth sphere
dimpled golf ball okay so it again so
the separation point is farther forward
on the dimpled ball that's true what are
the implications for this system huh
okay less drag and the way you can see
this is if I if I play this movie you
see that there's this kind of region in
this wake region of disturbance and in
the smooth cylinder it oscillates in
these big coherent vortical patterns and
it has a large broad wake which means it
has quite a lot of drag whereas in the
bottom flow the dimples both cause the
separation point to be farther and they
trip the system to turbulence and so you
have a kind of more constricted more
spatially compact wake region which is
lower drag so this dimple ball will
travel much farther than this movie ball
my turbulence professor the person who
taught me most of what I know about
turbulence actually consulted for the
like one of the World Golf Tour
associations on how many dimples a golf
ball should have so he's part of the
reason that golf ball dimples are nearly
optimal which is pretty cool okay so
that's one example this is the solution
of a very nonlinear pretty nasty partial
differential equation called the Navy or
stokes equation anytime you get in an
airplane
anytime you throw a football or you know
almost anything you can think about
fluid flows that are causing the forces
the drags the moments the lifts and it
all comes back to the solutions of this
partial differential equation so writing
down the partial differential equation I
didn't tell you what it is we need to
figure out what is the equation we're
solving we need to figure out how to
solve it and then we need to figure out
how to interpret the solutions that we
get okay so here I'm just showing you
this we
into an equation I never told you what
it is okay this is another one of my
favorite examples this is an example
from quantum mechanics so this is the
double slit experiment but visualized as
the solution to a partial differential
equation
some crazy stuff is happening back there
so quantum mechanics optics you know
fiber-optic lasers satellite
communications all of these kind of
electromagnetic quantum phenomena are
solutions of the nonlinear Schrodinger
equation very similar to the navier's
stokes equation actually if you write
down there one the approximations
they're actually the same weird so
anyway there's lots of PDEs in material
science so if you want to look at
elastic waves through a solid if you
want to look at the electromagnetic
properties of a material of a piece of
glass or plastic or crystal then you're
essentially talking about Schrodinger's
equation which is again a nasty
nonlinear PDE for wave propagation okay
so I'm gonna go through great lengths to
explain lots of physical interesting
examples of PDE s throughout the next
four or five weeks but to start I want
you to just get familiar with what is
the form of a partial differential
equation what are the pieces what are
the language of how we talk about these
things and then starting in the next
lecture on Wednesday we're gonna take a
physical system which is the heat
conduction in a rod and we're gonna
actually just work it all out
okay so we'll work out a physical system
we'll start with the physics we'll
derive the partial differential
equations we'll solve the partial
differential equations and then we'll
analyze our solution so that's what
we'll do on Friday okay so today we're
talking about partial differential
equations
and one of the things I like about this
is that it really synthesizes almost
every concept that we've learned in
class so far we're gonna be using
complex variables we're going to be
using vector calculus to write our PDE s
we're going to be thinking about the
solutions of these partial differential
equations in terms of the ordinary
differential equations which were very
familiar with at this point and this is
also going to motivate things that we
haven't learned yet like Fourier
analysis Laplace transforms and some of
the methods from data science ok ok so
basically the difference between a
partial differential equation and an
ordinary differential equation is simple
ordinary differential equations have one
independent variable and you take
derivatives with respect to that
variable so a PDE is essentially an
equation relating a multivalued function
and various partial derivatives of that
function so PDE is an equation relating
a multivariate function let's call this
function U and it's partial derivatives
okay this is just a definition so PDE is
an equation relating some function U
which is multivariate multi-valve
not multivalued has multiple variables
that depends on and various partial
derivatives of U okay so for example we
might have our function U be a function
of space and time and maybe this U is a
temperature okay so what I could have I
could have a circular rod of metal and I
could have some temperature distribution
on this maybe I've been hitting this end
with the blowtorch for the last five
minutes and this end has been dumped in
ice and so I have some temperature
distribution on this rod and I let it go
and I want to know what is the
temperature distribution at all points
in space for all future times T okay so
this function U which is a function of
space and time is the thing I want to
know I want to know what this
temperature distribution is and space
and time okay and so an example PDE
would be something like the heat
equation and the heat equation is you
know partial u partial T equals some
constant times partial u partial x
squared second derivative in space okay
so this is a heat equation I didn't tell
you why this is true for heat conduction
in a rod would have to go down to basic
physics to figure out why this is the
relationship that describes
heat conduction in a rod that's what
we're gonna do on on Friday but the
basic idea is that I have this partial
differential equation and this partial
differential equation relates partial
derivatives of the function I care about
you
okay so U is this temperature
distribution it has a temperature at
every point X and at every time T and I
can take its partial with respect to
time I can take its partial with respect
to space and I can relate them in this
partial differential equation and any
questions at this point make sense I
have some function I care about you and
I'm you know I have some essentially
this codes up the physics of the
situation in some relationship between
partial to partial derivatives and the
solution of this PDE is the function U
so the function I care about is the
solution U is the solution at my PDE
okay this is not I'm not trying to like
take a big step here let's just think
about what an OD e would look like so a
good example of an OD e is like the
bunny population and something like X
dot equals a times maybe I'll say P for
population my population dot equals some
constant C times my current bunny
population this is basically the same
kind of equation except that my bunny
population P is just a function of time
so P of T is my bunny population and so
there's no partial derivatives this is
just the derivative of my bunny
population in time is some constant
times my bunny population so the only
difference between a PDE and an OD e is
that the function you're trying to solve
for in a PDE
is more complicated it has more
dependencies it has dependencies for
example on space and time rather than
just on time okay so for example if I
wanted to build a model and I did this
once this is the first computer program
I ever wrote let's say you want to build
a model for the bunny population in a
field a really large field like a field
the size of Kansas so you could grid
this thing up so that you have one
square kilometer squares or maybe 10 or
100 square kilometer grid points and I
could have a population that depends on
x and y and on t okay so I could have my
bunny population now depending on which
location I'm in and on the time of my
simulation okay so if I have a spatial
equation where each of these boxes now
has some local dynamics maybe bunnies
really like to stay where they were born
and they like to grow then I might have
some spatial dynamics of bunny
populations maybe they'll eat all of the
resources over here and move to this
square maybe they'll eat all the
resources here and move to this square
and all the resources here and move to
this square and so you can take some
modified bunny equation some modified
bunny oh de and you can write that down
for every single grid cell and you can
actually have coupling between them
maybe bunnies move maybe once they grow
up they move one square over maybe they
move to where the most food is so they
diffuse to where there's a higher
concentration of food so this would
represent kind of a pictorial partial
differential equation that we could cook
up to represent spatial population
dynamics and these are actually really
really popular so you don't just do this
for bunnies you also do this for people
right we want to know where people will
go to look for jobs or to look for food
where fish go in the ocean
so that's an example of how we take our
simple OD e and we can turn it into a
PDE by writing it down at every single
grid point I'm gonna talk a lot more
about this example way later in the
class this is how we're gonna simulate
these kinds of partial differential
equations we're gonna box them up and
write them as a bunch of OD G's okay
okay one last thing I'm going to use
subscripts to denote partials so like
partial partial X so if I have u sub X
that's defined as partial u partial X
okay it's the X derivative of my
function u u sub T is partial u partial
T is everyone okay with that notation
yep okay good so what I want to do is
write down the three most important
differential equations that we're gonna
solve in this class we're probably gonna
spend about a week on each of these
major PDE s they're really important
because one they're simple enough we can
solve them so they're good models for
systems even if they're kind of
simplistic to they describe some of the
most useful physical systems like
vibrating strings or vibrating membranes
thermal transport fluid transport things
like that okay so I want to write down
the three canonical PDE s okay anyone
have a guess at what one of these
canonical
or partial differential equations that
you want to solve okay that one's way
complicated and it's built out of these
canonical PDE s so that's why we're
gonna use these because we can actually
understand these as building blocks for
things like nevier stokes what's another
simpler example
aegeon okay so I like heat diffusion so
I'm going to call that the second
equation the heat equation
okay what's another one the wave
equation is a good one which i think is
my first one wave equation what's an
example of an equation we've already
come across in for example complex
analysis and in vector calculus
Laplace's equation and look losses
equation is a lot like the heat equation
as we'll see and you can kind of the
heat equation is like a fancier version
of the Laplace equation okay so the wave
equation I'm just going to write this
down and then we're going to talk about
what all of the terms mean so the wave
equation is utt equals some constant
squared partial squared you remember
this is the partial squared is the
laplacian operator it's like del squared
so sum of second derivatives the heat
equation is U T equals some positive
constant times the same thing the
laplacian of u and the pluses equation
it's just getting simpler and simpler
right second partial derivative and u
equals this first partial derivative of
U equals basically the same thing and
now for Laplace's equation we have 0
equals our laplacian operator and you
okay so I'm going to go through and
actually tell you what you means and
what why we get all of these equations
and what the terms mean in a minute so
let me just write this down in 1d this
is the general vector form so this is
the
general vector form let me write down
you know in in one view okay so that we
really understand what this is actually
saying so in 1d what is the laplacian of
my function u partial squared u partial
x squared right so it's u TT equals some
positive constant u xx
the second partial derivative with
respect to time of my function is equal
to some positive number times the second
partial derivative of my function with
respect to X and the reason we care
about the wave equation is because it
can model things like vibrating strings
or membranes or drums or anything the
vibrates so your earbuds are based on
the wave equation ok so let's say I have
some taut string and I pluck the string
or I put some wave on the string by
varying my boundary conditions so now I
have some some displacements on my
string then this height Y is equal to my
function U of X and T so the thing I
care about is I want to know how is the
string going to move if I pluck it or if
I do something to it this equation tells
me how this function U evolves in time
and space
now I haven't told you why this is the
equation for a wave we have to derive
that from physics we have to actually
think about what are the forces acting
on this string and this is essentially
just a statement of F equals MA but
we'll come to that later so what is this
string do if I grab it from the middle
and I pull down and I let go
goes up and down and how does it go up
and down sinusoidally okay so I would
imagine that some combination of sine
waves might be the solution of this
equation so U of X and he might be
something like sine of X times some
other sine of you know T right there
might be sine some frequency in X and
some frequency and T that this thing is
doing because if this thing is actually
going to look like a sine wave in X or
maybe a cosine wave in X and it's also
going to be moving up and down also
sinusoidal e in time so I'm thinking
that this is going to be sines and
cosines in space and in time okay and we
know that that's what's what's happening
so probably on Monday we'll actually
work this example out and we'll derive
the Fourier expansion because the sums
of sines are also solutions because I
can have a superposition okay I don't
want to give too much away too early
let's say about the heat equation so
what is this equation in 1d UT doesn't
change and okay my constant times u xx
right in 1d now these seem very very
similar right they're almost exactly the
same except that this one has a first
partial derivative and time on the left
and this one has a second partial
derivative in time it seems like a small
difference but it's actually a huge
difference they're entirely different
classes of partial differential
equations with wildly different
solutions so the top one is called a
hyperbolic PDE and the bottom one is
called a parabolic PDE not that that
name means anything right now I just
want you to know what things are called
and this parabolic PDE so this system is
going to have sines and cosines
the solutions right they're gonna
oscillate in time and in space let's
think about a heat equation so I told
you this is the heat equation and so now
we have a very very thin circular rod of
steel and let's say that I have a
blowtorch and I just give this thing an
impulsive temperature at time zero at
that location so my temperature is flat
flat flat flat really hot and then flat
what is this temperature going to do in
time okay it's going to distribute
outwards in what way is it going to
distribute outwards let's say that's a
good word for how it's going to do that
okay so it's going to spread out as a
Gaussian what else is it going to do
what does he do when it's localized in
one place and then it spreads to another
place diffuses okay so we have diffusion
of heat which means that at time maybe
one second I have a sharp gaussian and
at time 10 seconds i have a flatter
Gaussian at at time a bajillion seconds
I'm assuming that this is an insulated
rod at time a bajillion seconds it's
just a constant slightly higher constant
temperature okay so this is Gaussian
diffusion it doesn't look at all like
sines and cosines
this is sines and cosines yes I think it
is yeah so somehow I just impulsively
heat it in one location but I'm kind of
holding the whole thing insulated
afterwards so that it keeps it retains
all of its added thermal energy okay so
this tiny tiny difference one partial
derivative in time later I go from
having a solution which is purely
oscillatory sines and cosines to having
a solution which is Gaussian diffusion
okay now I'm going to teach you how to
solve these systems by hand
and a dirty secret is that you're not
going to solve a lot of partial
differential equations by hand in the
real world in real life you will
occasionally it's good to know how to do
them it's good to know the general
techniques to solve these but what I
really care about far more than any of
the mathematical details is I want you
to understand why these equations look
the way they do and what it means
physically in terms of the solution okay
I want ten twenty years from now you
didn't know that a wave equation looks
like this and has these kinds of
solutions and the heat equation looks
like this and has these kinds of
solutions that's what matters okay okay
and then Laplace's equation is a little
funny so I'm not going to write it in 1d
I'm gonna write it in 2d 2d for Laplace
right because the plus doesn't have any
time dependence so there's no notion of
time in this equation at all it's just
spatial derivatives so what is the what
is the laplacian
in two spatial variables x and y
partial squared view partial x squared
plus partial u partial y squared equals
0 and I'm going to write this in the
same notation up here this is just u X X
plus uy y equals 0 that's the process
equations and two variables what's kind
of cool about this is that Laplace's
equation looks a lot like the heat
equation if u T equals zero right my
heat equation in 2d is U T equals alpha
squared u xx plus u YY right so if if my
time derivative of U is zero then I
recover Laplace's equation what does
that mean physically what does it mean
for my time derivative of U to be zero
in the heat equation steady heat
distribution means there's no thermal
transport there's no heat flux anywhere
the temperature distribution is steady
and when does that happen
well it happens when all of these
diffusions balance out to zero that's
when it happens okay so it happens when
the proccess equation is solved so for
example the infinite time solution of
this Gaussian diffusion is a solution of
Laplace's equation you can verify that a
constant in space and time solves this
equation okay so these are the three
canonical partial differential equations
we're going to use these as examples and
building blocks for all of the PDEs that
we're going to learn in this class and
all of the methods that we can actually
use to solve things by hand come from
these basic building blocks okay that's
not to say that there are not other
important PDS but these are kind of
especially important and in every case
we care about solving for you our
function of interest either our
temperature distribution or our
displacement of the string in space and
in time okay any questions before we
kind of move on to some more technical
details
I've got any more questions about this
this is the building blocks of all of
physical reality
nothing now
okay so what are some of the properties
of these partial differential equations
when I when you look at these PDE s how
do you tell them apart what are the
distinguishing characteristics of these
PDE s that tell them apart from other
peopie's sorry
okay the order what is the order refer
to so the first one is ordering okay
second order in time first order in time
no order n time no time dependence and
second order in space second order in
space second order in space so these are
all second order spatial partial
differential equations and they have
differing orders in time good okay
what's another property of these PDE s
what were the classifications and Odie's
what were some of the main
classifications we had for ordinary
differential equations
linear or non-linear so are these linear
or non-linear OD Peas
we start writing this down this is
important so these are linear second
order so usually when you talk about
order you're just talking about the
highest order so even though this one's
first order in time it's second order in
space that's the second order equation
and what's the last what's another
property of OD is that was really
important to distinguish what kinds of
Odie's were easier to solve all assuming
they were linear what do you say anyway
homogeneous forces in homogeneous so
what does that mean again is there a
forcing function or not so do these
things have an additional forcing term
external forcing okay so these are
homogeneous okay in homogeneous would be
if I had like a plus F you know where
I'm externally forcing so in this
problem if I had this blowtorch and I
started moving it around that would be
an inhomogeneous PDE and I would need to
add something to this equation okay so
these are linear second order
homogeneous PDE s okay great so the
order doesn't really matter that much I
can solve fourth order PDE use tenth
order PDE use it doesn't matter they're
all basically the same techniques
homogeneous versus in homogeneous it's
very very very similar to the case of
Odie's and we'll talk about that later
you essentially have your principal
solution plus your particular solution
but the difference between linear and
nonlinear makes a huge difference just
like it did in Odie's
so in OD e's an equation being linear
versus nonlinear was the difference
between us being able to solve it and
not right and that's also true here so
what I want to do is I want to talk to
you now about what it means for a
partial differential equation to be
linear and why that's so important
okay and I also want to show you what
the hallmarks of linear versus nonlinear
PDEs are so you know when it's something
you can solve or when it's something
that's going to be really really
difficult
okay so linear P DS are built using
linear operators and I'm gonna call
these linear operators l so just a poll
how many of you have worked with PDEs
before in a class how many have not okay
and how many of you have seen linear
operators before defined or used at some
point in life
how many have not okay so the nice thing
about linear operators are that they're
pretty simple and intuitive and they
really make a lot of the notions that
we're going to talk about very precise
and easy to work with so a linear
operator I'm gonna give you examples of
linear operators first and then I'm
going to tell you what they mean so two
examples are multiplication by a number
multiplication by a constant and a
second example is you know taking the
partial derivative so I'm going to call
this first linear operator l1 of my
function U so linear operators operate
on functions U is the solution to my PD
it's the thing I care about so l1 of you
might be five times u that's a linear
operator or partial derivative I might
have a second linear operator which is
partial u partial X okay so what does it
mean to be linear well first of all I
can compose these functions so I could
say what
is l1 of l2 of you well what's l2 of you
partial partial X so what's l1 of l2 of
you five times partial partial X of you
okay so I can build up expressions by
taking by taking compositions of these
linear operators okay
a third really important one is addition
probably the most important one and I
left it out of my notes seems silly so
addition is really important so l3 of
you would be like
so this is actually called by linearity
and there's a reason I left it out of my
notes because it's confusing so we'll
talk about this one later but addition
of functions is basically also linear
okay so what does it mean to be linear
what it means to be linear is so L is a
linear operator if and only if L of the
sum of two functions I'm going to erase
this bilinear operator because it's just
confusing right now okay
so L is a linear operator if and only if
so u1 plus u2 is also a function right
and I can apply my linear operator to
this new function and if what I get out
is the same as L of my first function
plus L of my second function then it's a
linear operator l is the linear operator
another thing that has to be true is
that L of some number times U has to be
that number times L of U so this is for
any number and this is for all functions
u1 and u2
so linear basically means what we think
it means things add up like if I take
the linear function of u1 plus u2
it's just the linear function of u1 plus
the linear function of U 2 and we can
pretty easily verify that these two
things are in fact linear so let's just
do it for l1 so what's l1 of u1 plus u2
it's five times this thing which is u1
plus u2 and because of the distributive
property of like real numbers you get
five u 1 + 5 u 2 which does in fact
equal my linear function of U 1 plus my
linear function of u 2 okay so this
property property a is satisfied for
this linear function okay it doesn't
even matter what u 1 and u 2 are I
didn't I didn't have to use any property
or any special knowledge of what you
want or you two are that's true for all
functions and you can verify property B
the same way it's super easy
let's try l2 of u1 plus u2 so what is my
second linear operator on u1 plus u2
partial partial X applied to my new
function u1 plus u2 now if I actually
wrote down the limit definition of this
derivative on this function you would
find that you could split it up into two
limits limits with respect to X going to
0 of u1 and of u2 and you can show that
this actually splits up into partial u 1
partial X plus partial u 2 partial X try
this out for a function like try this
out 4x squared plus sine of X wait we
know that the derivative of x squared
plus sine of X is the derivative of x
squared
plus the derivative of sine of X right
this is something we've all known for a
long time and that equals L two of my
first function plus L 2 of my second
function ok any questions about this
linearity okay so these are linear
because they're built up in terms of
partial derivatives you can verify that
the second partial derivative of a
function is linear and I would like you
to do that you should definitely verify
that you know the second partial
derivative any combination of second
partials partial with respect to X and
why still a linear linear operator so
these are linear equations because
they're written in terms of linear
operators on you okay let me give you an
example of something that's a little
weird that is not exactly linear but
it's quite it's close its quasi linear
or affine linear
so a good example is addition by a
constant okay so what about linear
operator 3 which is addition by a
constant so L 3 of U equals u plus 7 is
this a linear operator okay why not
or why so you should be able to put a 20
inside of L 2 and get the same thing so
how you get on the left side of the
board okay this is a really interesting
point I had not thought about but for
linear operators these should be
commutative that's not always true
actually
that's not always true no because if I
have a matrix a that's a linear operator
and if I have a matrix B that's a linear
operator but a times B does not always
equal B times a it's only for special
matrices a and B that that's true but
it's a really good idea and it is true
for this example it's true for scalar
linear operators okay but it's not true
in general for vector linear operators
that's a really good idea so the basic
thing we're going to try to check is
that L 3 our third linear operator of u
1 plus u 2 should equal that linear
operator on u 1 plus that linear
operator on you two so this equals u 1
plus u 2 plus 7 right
but that does not equal u 1 plus 7 plus
u 2 plus 7 which would be what I need
right that would be L 3 like what we
need is for this to equal the linear
operator on u 1 plus linear
later on you too and it's not because I
would get an extra seven okay so this is
not a linear operator because it's seven
shy of being a linear operator but it's
called an affine linear operator and it
has a lot of the same properties as
linear for lots of applications but
that's all I'm gonna mention about
affine linear okay so what I want to do
in the last five minutes of class are
I've told you about what makes an
operator linear we know that our three
canonical examples the wave equation the
heat equation and Laplace's equation are
all linear and so now I think I should
tell you about what nonlinear functions
look like and how to spot them okay
so we have lots and lots of great tools
to understand linear PDE s just like we
can understand linear ode E's and solve
them by hand but nonlinear PDEs
are very hard to solve almost none of
them can be solved by hand and
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on how you look at it most of the
physical systems of interests are
nonlinear it's a lot of what makes
things interesting is that they're
nonlinear so some examples of
non-linearity okay so we know what
linear are what are some examples of
non-linearity so what are some examples
of n of you that are nonlinear
nobody say caught up to two derivatives
yes cosines yes
simpler powers u squared u squared is
definitely nonlinear u cubed is
nonlinear you to the force is nonlinear
so let's try this let's try n of u 1
plus u 2 I get u 1 plus u 2 squared is
u1 squared plus u2 squared plus 2 u on
YouTube
this part is n of u 1 plus n of u 2 plus
all this extra stuff these extra terms
make it so that this is not linear it
does not satisfy the first property of
being linear good okay you can also do
that for cosines the way I think about
cosines is that they're a power series
of powers which are each nonlinear
logarithms Exponential's also non linear
products are a really good one so let's
say that I have n of u equals u times u
X this is a really popular common one
I'm gonna take you times if partial with
respect to X just a product any products
so these are powers and any products are
also non linear and you can think of U
squared it's basically the product of U
and u so U and UX is probably also going
to be non linear I'll let you verify
this one but it's basically the same
idea if you plug u 1 plus u 2 into here
you get the thing you need plus a bunch
of extra cross terms that make it so
it's not linear absolute value is a good
example of a non linear function so if n
of u equals absolute value of U that's a
non linear really simple example is like
let's say an N of 5 minus
and what's in a 5-7 positive - right
okay what's n of five plus n of minus
7/12 okay so that one's nonlinear - I
really want to write down a good example
of a nonlinear equation but I probably
won't have time to explain anything
about it so a really important example
is called the burgers equation how many
of you have heard of burgers equation
it's the Tastee equation burgers
equation is the partial in time plus u
times UX this non-linear linearity here
equals some number nu times u xx okay
so what we have here is diffusion UT
equals if I got rid of this middle part
it would look like the heat equation if
I got rid of this part it would look
like a nonlinear convection so this is
my nonlinear convection term and this is
a really important model for how shock
waves form in physical systems ok so
this is the toy problem that we use to
understand shock waves like in
hypersonic vehicles or rockets or shock
tubes or anything this is the example so
this term this nonlinear term forms
shock waves and this viscous term
spreads the shock waves out and we're
going to talk a lot more about this
example I could write it in vector form
and I'll do that later all right I'll
see you all on Friday
[Music]
you